hi I'm normal male pakka I work for
Wolfram research and I'm a kernel
developer here my talk today is about
data visualizations in the form language
so before I get started let me give you
a brief overview of what I'm going to be
talking about I'll be talking about the
very basics of representing dates in the
wolfman language there is a lot of
functionality around working with dates
nobleton language most of it is going to
be out of the scope of this talk what I
will be dealing with is the interaction
between the different date
representations and the visualization
functions so we'll take a look at few a
few date plots and how they visualize
data then we'll take a look at the
features and options that give us a way
to work with dates from within the
visualization functions and then finally
we'll take a look at a few applications
built on top of the date features as
well as as well as date plots thank you
okay so let's get started the Bolton
language has a few ways to represent
dates and here here's a list of some of
the representations and I've tried to
order this amount in the order of their
increasing sophistication in the sense
that as you go down this list you can
hold and pack more information into the
into the representations and this is
important from the point of view of
visualization functions because the more
information we have inside the
visualization functions more we can do
with them and the richer the
visualization will look so absolute time
is the simplest way to represent date
information in in the wolfman language
and we set it to 0 on the first day of
the year nineteen hundred and then we
count the number of seconds so here for
example we have a list of
from here for example we have lists of
absolute dates represented as absolute
time and value pairs and we feed that
into the visualization function in this
case data list plot and as you would
expect you see you'll see the time being
plotted on on the x-axis is it expect
dates string and date list are our more
human readable form of their
presentation and you will be able to see
this in any of the applications or on
the web where you see come across time
stamps and and the same thing you can
again plug this into the visualization
functions and they will they will plot
the data data object is a is a more
packaged and internally consistent
representation for for dates and this
gives us features like for example
validation so we have functions like
data object queue which should be able
to make your life easy in terms of
processing and filtering data before you
pass them on to visualization functions
time series is an even more packaged
representation where you can give it x
and values and it'll put it into a time
series object among other things and it
will time series is it has a whole slew
of features which will help you sort of
fine tune what kind of information you
want to encode in that object and
there's a whole talk on time series
tomorrow but time series event series
and other temporal data are all accepted
by date visualization functions and they
will plot them directly so this is even
series which is a more discrete form of
the time series about and here I want to
take a quick look at a
an example so here I'm getting Christmas
holidays for for the United States from
holiday calendar from year 2000 up on 12
2016 and I'm constructing an event
series to plot using data list step lot
and the values are the the day values
for the holidays and the time is a
series of data objects and as you would
expect just like in the above plot here
it goes ahead and plots the event series
without any problem but I also want to
do the same thing in the second plot in
the plot below you can see that the data
being plotted is simply the values and
there is no data information in there
but there is a second argument to
dateless step lot here which will
specify for the plot to treat the values
as periodic time data so here it's
telling the plot that you know the
values start off on Christmas Day in two
thousand in its periodic yearly and so
you get the same plot as a bell but this
is just to show that date plots are not
simply getting the encoded date formats
and plotting them but we also attempt to
make them like true citizens of this
date family of functions so in this case
we are giving the option for you to sort
of retrofit your data with time
information so that you can quickly look
at what the visualization will look like
before you want to if you want to can go
go ahead and then process your data to
add that information back in of course
you want to get all the full-blown sort
of features that you would get with time
series etc if you wanted to create a
time series but it's a quick and easy
way for you to sort of visualize the
data beforehand on the other end of the
spectrum you have
data coming in from Wolfram sources so
for example financial data here and
these packets contain lots of
information in them and many different
time series in many instances and we
have a whole class of charting functions
that deal with visualizing these packets
and financial charts do that and here
we're looking at Renko chart that's
showing the stock information for Apple
so I don't know why the projector is
doing that I'm sorry about that so just
to summarize date visualization
functions will accept data in any of the
data representations in the wolfman
language so here's a nice little grid
that you can see with on the left-hand
side you have dates as objects lists and
strings and on the right hand side and
plotting date histogram for these values
and and it knows what to do with it it
takes the that information and plots the
time information but just in case you
want to give it a time series it will
again do the right thing it'll go ahead
and ignore the values and just plug the
time and like we've seen about if you
give the date list plot or dateless step
block the same information that same
time series then it will obviously plot
the values as well so the date functions
are very smart about what to do with
these representations when you give it
to them the same thing is with
association is the keys are ignored and
you get a nice plot of the time so again
to highlight if you give the same time
series to a date visualization and the
non date visualization as you can see
the top one will plot the time the
bottom wall will plot the values so with
that in mind let's take a look at a very
simple data set and look at the
different visualization functions
and how they deal with it so here is a
data set of holidays for the year 2016
this is derived from holiday calendar
data and for a bunch of countries and
the first thing I'm trying to do here is
to just plot a date histogram with that
data and I'm asking it to bin by month
and give a layout of stack so that I can
actually see the different countries on
the histogram and so that's that this is
one kind of visualization you can get
from that data and you can see the
January's is a popular month for
holidays and if i were to sort of look
at this histogram and guess as to which
country has the max in number of
holidays for 2016 i would ideally look
at the colors and and say you know take
a guess maybe russia looks like Russia I
don't know we'll take a look at it
timeline plot is a new function that we
added and again this gives you a
different kind of view on the same data
set this gives you more of the spread of
the holidays throughout the year and I
have two plots here one is a plain
timeline plot another one has has all
kinds of labels and tooltips attached to
it and I think it's going to show up
terribly on the projector here but it
has tool tips for with flags of the
countries and and as you can see you can
hear you have a nice spread
visualization of those holidays moving
on the same data if you apply the
dateless plug this is looking more
traditional now and you have the time on
x-axis and I've plotted the Y values as
a number of holidays so now it becomes
clear that Japan is leading in the
number of all days 4 2016 followed by
Russia Canada and the United States
looks like dateless step lot is yet
another new plot that we added built on
top of list step plot
this again gives you a different kind of
visualization and it gives its it plots
steps where where the data changes and
as you can see here this kind of plot
for this kind of data set is helpful to
see how much time has elapsed between
holidays so it looks like Germany as
like a long stretch without any holidays
in them so when you have date
visualization functions that take data
in the form of dates it it's reasonable
to assume that you would be able to
specify options that work on those data
to also respect these specifications and
that's exactly what's happening here we
have plot range and i'm specifying plot
range as the date string and grid lines
and attempting to plot a grid line for
independence day and that's that's
exactly what you see on the on the plot
there in addition to supporting options
and wrappers and the usual features that
all visualization functions have we also
added some new options for the different
date functions and this is one of them
that's worth mentioning which is a date
function for dateless plot and what it
does is it applies the function to the
data on the fly and if you take this in
conjunction with all functions that are
that work with data with dates in the
wolfman language it becomes really
powerful so for example here I'm
applying date round and I'm sort of
collecting all my holidays for the month
to the end of the month so you have nice
steps for each month for the holidays as
opposed to the plot on the top there
which shows you the steps at points
where the holidays occur day tix format
is another nice option that allows you
to format
the labels for the time axis and so for
date histogram here you can see for the
same data set this is just a random
sampling of four of the name
specifications that we have and in this
case some of them don't make sense
because i only have data for one year
but you can see that it supports a whole
bunch of name specifications for for the
tix labels and you can pick the ones
that you like for your data moving on
date reduction is a very powerful option
for date histogram what it does is it as
it tells the histogram to treat the data
that it's binning as though it were
cyclical reduced to the period that you
specify with data reduction so in this
case you have data for the whole year
for the holidays and I'm asking it to
reduce it to a month and you can see
that the first day of the month seems to
be very popular for holidays this year
for this group of countries time zone is
more of an option really for the date
functions and the functions that work on
data objects but date histogram does
support it and you can specify the time
zone and force the time zone for the
data that is being bin and so in the top
plot here I am specifying a time zone
that is forcing the holidays on two
different dates and so you can see the
bins shuffling around a little bit yep
yep yes that does over I did yeah for
that's right yep so let's take a look at
an example application really trading
chart is the really the poster child for
for an application built on top of date
functions so it this is a financial
chart and it's getting its data from
financial data from from Wolfram data
sources but you can see that we are
already using date histogram at the
bottom here in the dateless plot and we
have all kinds of nice controls
clickable controls to change the plot
range for for the plot but on top of
that we can do a whole bunch of things
that have no idea what they do but this
is all information that is really
encoded in in the time series so you can
add all kinds of bands you can have nice
overlays with information from the
series that is being plotted so so this
is really a very good example of how you
can build powerful visualization example
occations right inside your notebook or
your web browser or whatever it is that
you're using as your interface this is
really fine demonstration of what we can
do just because the visualization
functions now support all these kinds of
representations that are coming in from
various sources so what if you want to
do deal with data that's in the wild so
here is an example with information from
a from a git repository so one thing we
notice is that version control programs
have a lot of date information that can
be useful and insightful so here I'm
looking at the colonel repo for the
stable linux kernel and so you can check
that out with get and extract the time
stamps for commits and import it into
the wolfman language and then I'm doing
a little bit of
massaging on the data to get into a
format that I can easily plug in to date
objects and so finally I have a list of
data objects for the commit times for
the Linux kernel and I can go ahead and
do straight away plug it into data
histogram and this is the histogram of
all the commits into the Linux kernel
over time and you can see that there are
some weirdness going on here because
there's some artifacts because
apparently the commits for links going
to go all the way back to nineteen
seventy and all the way into the future
to twenty thirty seven so not sure where
that's coming from but you can do a
little bit of data cleaning and then
you'll get in real nice histogram of the
ranges that we are interested in so
nothing you know shocking year the
number of commits have been going up
over time and we can we can do a date
reduction on that and see that it's
pretty uniform throughout the year just
a little bit of dip in late summer and
probably during the holidays October
does do it does seem to be a month with
very high commits or higher commits and
then so that's probably will probably
have the same number of commits this
year symbol number of commits this year
is next at last one finally I'm this
just a change of look and pulling in
some penguins from Wolfram Alpha and
using that as chart elements for the
date histogram so really the story is
here I guess that we can you know fit
all these technologies that we have
together and make some really compelling
visualizations really quickly in in the
Wolfram language continuing on with the
analysis I want to see the contribution
of Linux Linus himself to the Linux
kernel so we can do the same thing here
I'm extracting time stamps for commits
authored by Linus going through the same
drill of yeah massaging the data and
getting it
to data objects and here I'm creating a
nice Association and plugging it into
dateless plot and you can see the plot
of Linus's commits to the colonel over
time and finally we can show both of
them together and that's what it looks
like so it looks like Linux kernel has
attracted a few more developers over the
years and finally one last example that
I want to show you that we built is
clogged gauge and it uses a lot of
graphics in dynamic technology but
really the core the core of the
information that's showing is gates and
and here it's doing it's doing its thing
using absolute time and it's telling me
it's time for me to stop so I guess
that's the end of it just a few
announcements we have a really good page
that we built for marketing which shows
all the new features that we added to
the wolfman language since series stem
so if you have not visited that I would
encourage you to do that really it has
really beautiful graphics and really
nice applications there's a talk
tomorrow by my colleague gosha on time
series and if you're interested in the
technology behind time series that would
be a talk to attend and finally you I
believe you get a survey for the talks
that you're attending I don't encourage
you to go ahead and fill those out
because that'll give us more information
on what kind of talks you enjoy so we
can put together a good conference for
you next year thank
you